peace be with you welcome to the D charm
of your host you're like what are you
doing at you in a pajama what no it's
not a pajama this is a Brazilian Jujitsu
gracie jiu-jitsu uniform and I have the
Ultimate Fighting original champion the
Sports Illustrated did a feature of the
top 50 legendary most influential
athletes of all time
hoist Gracie's in the do show studio
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
this is the pink you know this is the
days of the teacher this is the thanks
Gracie how are you my friend
life is good in my world that's good
thank you I thank God I'm really excited
that you're on to show horse
Gracie legendary UFC champion you know
the Dean shows viewed internationally
all over the globe thank God and we're
blessed that you know we have you here
in the Dean show studio and I wanted to
talk to you a little bit we I've been
training Gracie jiu-jitsu for a long
time you're one of my original teachers
you know tell us briefly for the
audience some some people who still
ain't turned out to Gracie jiu-jitsu
tell us a little bit about yourself
please men talk about myself let's talk
about my father your father okay he's
the one who started the whole thing he's
the one he learned by watching and he
couldn't do it cause he was very small
my uncle's learned the art of jiu-jitsu
from the Japanese and I one day my
uncle's late for a class my father
Stepien told the student that he would
run the self-defense program and did
taught the student a class from that day
on the students take classes my father
doesn't my uncle's said man what are you
doing what you do when he was watching
he didn't create a new style a new
martial art he just had leverage to the
moves and so a smaller person could
defend himself against somebody bigger
and stronger let's go through some of
these fights people are seeing this big
guy I believe his name is Kimo right and
again we're talking to some people many
people don't know about Gracie's usually
they still think that look man I
nobody's taking me to the ground so now
you're on the ground right here and
people are thinking okay you got this
250 plus pound guy muscle pure muscle
what are you what are you about a bunny
you want a tea at that time you're
around same 180
what's your day yes twenty years now we
see your dad's there he's telling you
something he's telling you something
you're you're on your back what are you
thinking at this time well what happened
is to prove the effectiveness of his
Gracie jiu-jitsu we back in Brazil my
father my uncle's my cousin's my brother
start to challenge people to see which
style is the best and there's only one
way to find out gain occasional ring and
take all the rules
wait divisions there's no time limit no
gloves no rules and we've been doing
that in Brazil for many years my brother
Harlan came to America and brought the
same concept American create the UFC so
but then the beginning 20 years 21 down
21 years ago it was a eight-man
tournament so you had to fight three
fights in one night and I defeat all my
opponents three fights without breaking
a sweat just showing the technique of
the my father creator hmm so laughs once
America found out because what happens
in Brazil people don't know but once my
American found out we spread out all
over the world all over the world in the
second year see my brother Horning made
the tournament it was a 16-man
tournament so for fights in one night so
we had five four fights in the same
night with no time limit no way division
no rules
everything goes in a cage two men walk
in one walk out and I did four opponents
in the same night now right somebody as
a 200 all the opponents no weight limit
no weight limit no weight division so
I'm fighting as I'm 180 I'm fighting
guys 250 270 280 just their profession
on their style fighting that sumo
wrestler two against a kickboxer against
a wrestler against a judo player against
a boxer the best of the best so this is
like the best in karate the best and
athletes I mean not just okay black down
karate but they're at the top of their
level correct though the top of the
level but then the wood I mean was a
would impress the most it was the
those I was the smallest person beating
the guys who are not just big about
beating them without having to smash
their face submitting them with a
technique with a choke with the arm lock
and they will quit and like get out
clean face without having to be smash up
and that's not violent yeah arts a
self-defense art as gentle as possible
yes yeah so so now hope with kindness
with kindness that's right that's so
important yes and now you proved
obviously this is without a shadow of a
doubt have you ever had somebody now
today I know there was in the gray sea
Academy there was tell us about the time
it was it open for anyone it was a
challenge but anyone can come in there's
old footage people are seeing right now
that now this is in the Academy this is
even before the UFC it was a challenge
like how did you guys set that up before
the UFC does that I mean there was
always a student that trained karate or
trained grassley in Hue communities like
man my crack instructor I told him about
you guys and he said he doesn't believe
so we said well bring him on bring him
over who be glad to talk to him about it
so he bring the instructor over in this
shrunked is like whoa I don't think and
take mr. ground so we kind of it was it
wasn't exactly a fight because we'd
never beat them up yeah we just take
them down with more baptizing them
turned them into a turn them into
believers and Gracie jiu-jitsu so we
take them down with more looking like
okay my brother always say man don't
beat this guy up too bad
he's gonna be a future student hmm so we
treat them as a future students so the
guy who come in and I'll take them down
not even a slap to the face just control
them and show to them then they'll be
like oh man I'm trying my best over here
and horses doing nothing just
controlling taking this the ground
taking out of my game it's embarrassing
can I learn this liquor and again with
kindness and gentleness this is amazing
we'll be right back with more here with
legendary hoist Gracie on the Dean show
we'll be right back what are we doing
here
and where are we gonna go it's like we
just woke up one morning and then it's
welcome to the show don't ask any
questions just go with the flow make as
much money as you can and try your best
not to get broke copy everything you see
on the TV from the hairstyles to the
clothes and don't think too often just
do exactly as you're told
and if you ever get confused and just
turn towards the alcohol you still hear
thoughts then just turn up the radio as
you learn to live a lifestyle of drugs
sex and rock and roll but in all honesty
I just need to know is there more to the
cycle than growing and getting old
living and dying just to leave behind a
happy home and a whole lot of property
that somebody else is going to own I
just really need to know before the
caskets closed because I'm not willing
to gamble with my soul nor am I ready to
take any chances these are just simple
life questions and I'm just searching
for some answers like what are we doing
here and what is our purpose how did we
get here and who made us so perfect and
what happens once we go or is this world
all really worth it questions we don't
answer because apparently we don't
really have to there's no purpose to
this life and our existence is merely
natural then in that case please let me
ask you did you create yourself or was
it somebody else who had fashioned you
cuz you're a being that's impeccable
faultless and unparalleled you're a
product of supreme intelligence and I'm
merely being rational for there isn't a
camera on this earth that can come close
to the human eye nor a computer that can
compete alongside the human mind and if
the whole world was to come together we
wouldn't be able to create a single fly
so many signs yet we still deny the
science tries to justify that all this
could come from none when it's a simple
sum zero plus zero plus zero cannot
possibly ever give you one so from where
did all this order come for everything
has its origins a maker a creator of its
own I mean the only reason you're
watching this video is because somebody
had to press upload so we can believe in
the Big Bang but I'd rather believe in
he who caused it to explode allah the
creator of everything along with every
single soul the everliving the master
the only one who is in control unlike
his creation beyond our imagination and
no he's not a man nor does he have any
partners in association he's on his own
and though he did not ever leave us
alone just like every manufacturer he
left us with an instruction manual the
Quran and the slam and I'm sorry to jump
to conclusions but it's the only one
possible the only definition of God is
the one and only Supreme Being its
logical a book with zero contradictions
with miracles that are both scientific
and historical or revealed over 1400
years ago like the detailed description
of the human embryo the descriptions of
the human embryo and the grand cannot be
based on scientific knowledge in the
seventh and - the mountains as pegs
holding firm the earth below and the two
seas that don't mix in a complete
separate flow to the planets in orbit
alternating night and day as they stay
in flow the expansion of the universe
and the creation of everything from h2o
to the stories of the past and the
preservation of Pharaoh to identifying
the lowest point in the land
where Persia defeated Rome the gushing
fluid that created man in the glands
between the ribs and the backbone and
not a word has changed it's still the
same so please explain how all this was
known over 1400 years ago to a man who
couldn't read or write as you would
recite whatever the angel spoke and if
you still don't believe please try to
come up with something that's even close
but you can't so we took God as a
mockery and his messengers as a joke
dismiss these scriptures as legends and
tales of the ancient folk as we live
life according to our whims desires and
hopes saying this life is the only home
we will ever know we will lift and dive
and simply turn to bones yo low
correction after the grass dies the rain
arrives and it regrows and Allah
promises to do the same thing to your
very soul and bring you back from your
very fingertips to your toes as the
all-seeing Supreme Being watches our so
close and we are surely being tested in
our wealth our health and our self and
everything that we've been blessed with
so believed for we will surely be
resurrected and be brought back to our
Lord in a Kalpa every single deed as he
hands us our books and orders us to read
from the bats that are good and
everything in between
you yourself were sufficient for your
own accountability so don't be mad at me
you are the one who thought he wouldn't
come back to me I gave you a whole life
long to search after me but you were
busy in all that which was temporary so
read and glad tidings to all those who
believed and if you disbelieve read and
don't let that day be the first day you
find out what your life really means
read back here on the D show with the
original champion no time limits at that
time now you have weight divisions and
people are cross-training but this is
strictly Gracie Brazilian Jujitsu
against the best and any other Marge ma
chatte what were the rules there was no
rules no rules Hey everything goes every
much of men's agreement nobody in the
white garden but if they did there was
no punishment okay so that was like okay
we're not going to do that but if you
look if you choose to go to that low
level yeah that's on you okay but that
was like a men's agreement like vfc won
my final match after my third match
we're fine on that day that night it was
a shot go do I took him down he took a
bite of my ear we did a Mike Tyson on
you right my ear pull it off as I
whisper in his ears like men you
cheating he just give me a look like so
what huh
so when I got the choke on him I hold it
that's why you held the title Esther
days Cheney man now I let go and I wanna
amazing tell us about this the Sports
Illustrated with the magazine famous Mac
sports magazine they did a feature of
the 50 most influential athletes of all
times this right number 44
thank God it's amazing tell us about it
well you had today today I invite you
did was this Sunday no that's odd I
asked my manager about that and he said
his reporters that put out a vote on who
is the most influential athletes
I was wondering how come my father was
not in there yeah in ours because I'm a
product of his work
and his dementia probably because you
are the one that was a vehicle that
shows to the world on UFC by being two
three four opponents in one night yeah
the art of Gracie jiu-jitsu even though
your father is the one that created so
this was all so you had like legends
like Muhammad Ali who else is in a big
name when I leave Michael Jordan Michael
Jordan yeah parallel path I was the
second Brazil and that those other
Brazilian those in there too uh-huh have
you ever baseball players and Wayne
Gretzky and the most influential
athletes did you ever to this day have
anybody who wants to test you yeah no
that's kind of a fighting that's it you
fight for it back in Brazil now we get
paid to fight that's it yeah I guess
were adopted that tell us are you know
for the people that are looking to train
a martial art okay and they're watching
us and they're really like they that we
know that martial arts have so many
benefits but they're trying to pick okay
should I should I train karate kung-fu
and now they got hoist Gracie on the
Dean show why should I change it to
Gracie Persinger to why because it's the
best self-defense art out there the most
complete one I mean
martial art in general is the biggest
sports second biggest sports in the
world soccer is the first martial art in
general is the second any martial art is
good but Gracie jiu-jitsu is more
complete because you start standing up
it's like a karate for instance if you
take the cry guy down to the ground he
doesn't know what to do in Gracie's we
do wrestling they teach the people how
to pin each other down but isn't the
fight doesn't finish they force a fight
in the street you really going to depend
a person down so you have to know how to
submit the opponent yeah another
beautiful thing we see with we see a lot
of bad examples of teachers in in many
martial arts that now what fascinated
also me and I love as the the code of
conduct that the Gracie family also you
know expels
meaning that now you have like you said
this kindness
beating someone gently and kindly this
good these good mannerisms a good diet
you know good character that all of
these things are also part of the the
martial art how important is is because
you can end up learning you know marShon
be the most arrogant but it seems like
you trained your budget so you become
humble it's a martial art normally
teaches you that in general how to be
humble and that's the spirit of martial
art but with us I mean I don't drink
never drink never smoke we have the call
to Gracie diets not exactly diets and
more of our eating habits it's not I
can't afford to get sick on the day the
fight yeah so we eat everything we just
there's a few things that we don't eat
but it's mostly how we combine the food
so it's a way of life if people now
we're almost out of time if people want
to get a hold of you they let you travel
all over the world doing seminars is
that right
this year alone I just got back from
Quaid Dubai Abu Dhabi Hawaii Australia
this year and now I'm here how can
people get a hold of you - to learn more
about you know gracious Jiu Jitsu
tomorrow website host grace calm or at
real voice on Twitter
beautiful Facebook and Instagram you
know I like to thank you so much for
being with us we have a we got to go but
you can't come on addy show now get a
grip this is for you thank you so much
noise
thank you i bless you thank you so much
for being with you hope to see you again
soon thank you and that was legendary
hoist Gracie on the Dean show and now
you understand why we were wearing the
kimono the great the Jitsu gay have fun
trained in the martial arts learning
it's the most effective martial art in
the world
tune in every week to the Dean show
we'll see you next time here until then
same time same Channel don't forget
follow us on facebook like' us on
Twitter until next time peace
take that simple step that you ask your
maker to guide
that he'll guide you yes III advise this
a lot for people researching put your
head on the floor and in the in the
state of preparation like all the
prophets leaders and ask the creator of
the universe to show you the way to
guide you to the straight path and
someone who sincerely ask for guided Sao
Paulo will find it useful that's it